ciudades enteras inundadas Este es el
panorama en el estado de Río Grande do
Sur tras el paso de un ciclón extra
Tropical del pasado viernes Los Fuertes
vientos del fenómeno atmosférico dejaron
muertos desaparecidos y edificaciones
destruidas
estamos viviendo una pesadilla vamos a
necesitar mucha ayuda del Gobierno
Federal del gobierno Estatal y sabemos
que la comunidad y la región nos van a
ayudar a reconstruir
a construir nuevamente a pesar de la
aparente calma la alerta continúa las
autoridades hicieron un llamado a
permanecer atentos ante el riesgo que
suponen los posibles deslizamientos de
tierra la alarma hizo que los residentes
se refugiaran en instalaciones
deportivas Incluso en estas condiciones
no pierden la fe perdimos algunas cosas
estamos tristes Pero tenemos fe en Dios
que vamos a recuperar todo las labores
de ayuda ya están en marcha al menos
se rescate se efectuaron entre el
viernes y el sábado ahora es el momento
de que miremos a la gente de proteger a
las personas que han sido afectadas
darles cobijo asistencia atención a cada
uno de ellos para rescatar a aquellas
personas que aún necesitan sean
rescatadas Localizar a los desaparecidos
brindar asistencia a las personas
los damnificados se cuentan en 3,713
personas a diferencia de los ciclones
tropicales que se fortalecen en el mar
los extratropicales adquieren fuerza por
el choque de masas de aire en la
atmósfera
[Música]